ti bien je en ligne maintenant de
nouveau donc l'ambassadeur de France à
Bucharest Monsieur Le Breton vous
m'entendez je vous entends bien est-ce
que vous pouvez à l'heure qu'il est nous
faire un point de la situation est-ce
que les combats ce soir se poursuivent
avec la même intensité ou bien ont-ils
baissé
d'intensité ils continuent je dirais que
cet après-midi ils ont baissé
d'intensité tout au moins dans la zone
où se trouve
l'ambassade mais naturellement je ne
peux pas parler pour ensemble de la
viille des combats ont eu lieu dans la
zone sud et il y a toujours au nord un
certain nombre de poes de résistance qui
pose problème bien le Comité de salut
national annoncé tout à l'heure sa
victoire laissant à penser que ces
combats se continuait mais que il ne
s'agissait que de Poch de résistance de
miliciens qui ont le dos au mur est-ce
que vous qui connaissez parfaitement la
situation à Bucharest et en Roumanie
vous pensez que ces combats peuvent
durer un certain temps vous pensez que
l'armée rallée peut venir à bout de ces
de ces miliciens oui oui je pense je
pense en effet comme vous l'a dit le
Comité de salut national que il gagnera
la partie mais les hommes qui sont
restés fidèles à taosescu sont encore
assez bien organisés il peuvent faire
beaucoup de mal et ils sont en train
d'en faire maintenant l'armée est-elle
tout entière rallé je ne peux pas encore
le dire un certain nombre de de
signe n permettent de penser que
euh il reste encore des poches très
sérieuses et et des soldats très bien
organisés alors nous allons passer dans
un instant une interview de Monsieur
Duma le ministre d'affaires étrangères
français qui n'exclut pas de demander à
l'Union soviétique d'intervenir par
l'intermédiaire du pacte de Varsovie si
les événements se prolongent est-ce que
vous avez été saisi vous d'une demande
d'intervention quelconque de la France
sur le plan international par le conseil
de salut national non le conseil de
salut national m'a remercié ce matin
lorsque j'ai repris contact avec lui de
l'aide que nous apportons dans le
domaine humanitaire et en particulier on
est extrêmement sensible à la venue de
Monsieur Bernard Kouchner et des
médecins qui l'accompagnent ceci dit on
n'a absolument pas demandé une aide
militaire et je ne crois pas que
l'intention des autorités roumaines de à
l'Union
soviétique allô oui bien merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je je vous quitte un
instant parce que maintenant nous avons
en ligne et à l'image